scotus new Rapid spaceback has all the
markings of a top seller and of a
serious competitor for parent company
Volkswagen it follows the Rapide 5-door
hatchback and marks a widening of skotos
range in the compact segment it's not
the first time volkswagen has had
competition from its own subsidiary
which may explain why VW recently
tighten the reins and decreed somewhat
planar lines for skoda plate enough to
set it up visually from its pricier
volkswagen counterparts
that up he divided scooters Christoph
behringer places the Rapide in between
the Fabia and Octavia models saying the
new Rapid spaceback is their first small
hatchback and the strategically
important compact class the fresh
looking design is aimed at new car
buyers looking for a cheaper alternative
to the VW Golf even if a mate look cheap
this smart hatchback has showroom appeal
to give us a spot car tester a manual
says on the road the Rapid spaceback
keeps the promise made by its design
it's agile and maneuverable and fun to
navigate around bends the check car
maker depended heavily on its parent for
engineering support using the Gulf's
range of three gasolina three diesel
engines we tested the 1.2 liter TSI with
a standard fitted 6-speed transmission
it puts out 77 kilowatts of power
reaching a maximum speed of 193 km/h
most of the engines also come in a green
tech version there's also one extra
efficient diesel model the Green Line
addition
gosh go to Pete's scooter will be
offering the Rapid spaceback all over
Europe but its principal markets will be
in Central and Western Europe in Germany
coast appearing as sees the potential
for it to become one of the brand's
largest volume sellers dhamaka short of
it their headlights and grill helped to
integrate the front into the overall
design dynamic options include xenon
headlights fog lights and built-in
directional front lighting systems the
longer wheelbase means lots of legroom
and thanks to the space backs contours
even an inch more headroom and in the
sedan
the equipment line we tested the
elegance lived up to its name though not
quite achieving the quality of the gulf
the elegance line still includes lots of
hard plastic the new multifunctional
steering wheel takes after its big VW
brother the displays are clear and
simple the seats are comfortable and
provide ample legroom in both front and
back
the car also lives up to the name space
back with 415 litres of luggage capacity
the most in its class no other compact
can boast as much the gulf falls 35
litres short and because our reviewer
Emmanuel is impressed with a rapid
spaceback inside and out he can't find
anything to complain about and says all
together it's a really well-made car
plus the Rapid spaceback starts in some
3,000 euros less than the lowest price
VW Golf
a visionary and virtual concept the
mercedes-benz AMG vision Gran Turismo it
was specially designed for the gun to
lease most six console game the Mercedes
design team followed the same in-house
procedures for developing real world
production cars and prototypes it has
not yet apparent how far the fictional
AMG vision Gran Turismo resembles the
upcoming AMG GT Alfa Romeo presents its
latest sports coupe a the 4c the
two-seater incorporates engineering
previously deployed in the 8c
competizione a super sports car plus
materials such as carbon fiber and
aluminum the engines turbocharged
four-cylinder unit generates 176
kilowatts alpha plans to limit
productions just three and a half
thousand a year the four-seat hits the
market in Germany at just over 50000
euros
out there apparently the BMW website
says the x6 has the agility and elegance
of a coupe a and the impressive
versatility of a sport activity vehicle
and that the car draws its strength from
the magic of two exclusive automobile
worlds our tester motto says you could
argue about the form and elegance but
when it comes to versatility we'll have
to find out for ourselves the x6 has
been around since 2008 but it was never
a big seller now BMWs decked it out with
a new engine and better handling to try
and change that
the execs montes feels very safe in the
x6 in wet conditions it starts to shift
over the front wheels the car is pretty
heavy but Montes finds it manageable and
it never feels unsafe we're testing the
diesel-powered xdrive30d with an output
of a hundred and eighty kilowatts it can
hit a hundred kilometers an hour and 7.5
seconds and has a maximum speed of 222
opinion is divided over the car's
exterior design some people think it's
graceful and elegant for others it's as
clunky as a tank so here's our disguises
Montes says you have to consider storage
space when you're looking at the
versatility of an SUV the x6 is a bit
limited in terms of luggage capacity if
you take a look in the trunk it's deep
and wide but not very high fly this deck
off a home I even miss Donnelly show
even if he takes the rear shelf out it
doesn't change much Victoire plus and
that I can click your vanish the poop a
style rear reflects the character of the
x6 LED rear lights come as standard
whatever you need the x64 there's plenty
of room on the inside and on top of that
the interior also features a lot of
extra storage options the central
console opens up to create a handy spot
close to the driver there's also room to
keep further items in the dashboard as
expected there's a range of driver
assists the car sighs and handling mean
bumps in the road or easily absorbed but
there's a snag other than when it comes
to the view Matusz isn't sure if it
matches an SUV when he looks out of the
back he can hardly see a thing the front
columns to the left and right or wide
and then with the wing mirrors next to
them the view is restricted monta says
the sitting position is like being in a
coop a if he wants a better view of the
hood like he's used to with SUVs then he
needs to raise the seat a lot maybe he's
just too small for this car some of
these things it's from zero to roughly
collectors anticline figures out which
my destiny the x6 isn't suited to all
types of driving for people in urban
areas the length of almost 5 meters
could prove difficult to handle but the
car makes up for that with a comfortable
interior
Lunds it's the driver's seat is
comfortable and the ergonomics are
typically sound for a BMW it's a diesel
engine but one that consumes 10 to 11
liters for 100 kilometers if you put
your foot down montes doesn't think
that's too high for a car this big and
heavy it could be more efficient but
maybe the next generation will deal with
that issue even so Matusz wouldn't buy
this car himself a Fermi boy no call
from hoodies and get hostility that's a
decision for consumers to make
themselves prices for the x6 in Germany
started just under sixty thousand euros
Ryan are sharply as a coach driver we
meet him in the South of France and take
a short trip together on Cetera's new
luxury coach Center has been making this
kind of vehicle in Germany for over 50
years today it's part of daimler and
spite of its size the bus maneuvers
astonishingly well
as if this s writer says right from the
first the coach had the feel of an
ordinary car he mentions the grip on the
steering wheel the coherence of the
steering and the steering transmission
which is very smooth he says the high
seat position thumbs drivers see what's
coming they can react to situations and
when it comes to the field of the
vehicle and driver dynamics Reiner says
it does the job what's the spots the
center of top-class 500 is just under 4
meters high and over 13 meters in length
it has an eight-year powershift
transmission and meets the very latest
safety standards the 12.8 liter engine
capacity achieves 350 kilowatts of power
and 2300 newton meters of torque the new
engine is more efficient than its
predecessor and meets the Euro 6
emission standards that will come into
force in the next year
it took four years to develop the coach
escaped I danisha our stock from Daimler
says the one guiding principle behind
the development of the series was quite
simply to make the top class 500 the
peak of Coach building with cutting-edge
technology and a unit and distinctive
design that stays true to its brand
values and provides passengers with
extraordinary comfort ningun 45acp our
journey takes us to the airport in the
city of nice
the coach can carry 55 passengers the
merkon family is happy to let us show
for them to their hotel while they put
the coach to the test
dadar Valeria is immediately drawn to
the panoramic glass roof which gives the
coach and airy ambience passengers can
also see the view up ahead on monitors
as it does Dario says it looks good on
the outside and the inside is especially
nice because everything's leather he
says normal city buses don't necessarily
have panoramic views he also says the
coach has plenty of room Valeria says
coaches aren't usually so simple they're
always cramped but here you have a lot
of room she says she likes the light
colored leather seats the best
compromise mrs. macaanto says she works
in the travel industry and sells coach
tours she says she likes this coach
because it offers comfort to the
passenger she also likes the fact that
it's wide and not too tight right uncle
won't have it that's just ended we
dropped the macaanto family off at their
hotel after a smooth ride and take the
opportunity to ask Reiner how he's doing
in the driver's seat
they need us guns eco he says the whole
cockpit area is set up for the driver
every button is in the right position so
the driver just has to press at once and
he knows where it is he says the buttons
are arranged logically so drivers can
find them straight away and they're in
the best possible position another thing
Reiner mentions is that the drivers
themselves can change the buttons to
suit them and put them in other spots he
says that's typical for central opposed
it so important so neilan our task is
set the top class 500 scores well with
our driver and gets the thumbs-up from
passengers to
it has the grace of a bad knee knee
sculpture and contours that could have
been carved by Michelangelo the bits are
any 5300 GT has classic Italian styling
written all over it but for its actual
creator this sports car wasn't just
about its captivating looks it bears the
hallmark of Giotto bit savini arguably
the most talented racing car constructor
of the 1960s the 5300 gt's mission was
to leave the competition for dust on the
racetrack and fill its creator with
pride bit cerini the very name still
makes Ferrari or Maserati owners nervous
it's maker had high hopes of it becoming
the new star in the sports car horizon
on the back of triumphs on the track but
this supernova on four wheels fizzled
out all too rapidly today most people
wouldn't even recognize a 5,300 GT Harry
Oswald is the happy owner of one of
these rare racers the 5300 GT was built
between 1964 and 68 in a limited edition
according to some sources production
amounted to just 70 and assembled
specimens Giotto been savini was born in
Livorno in 1926 he is considered one of
the most influential constructors in the
history of motorsports
he spent five years at Ferrari as
developer designer test driver and chief
engineer among his accomplishments
they're the iconic GTO eventually there
was a clash of egos between him and boss
Enzo Ferrari leading to his departure
the GTO went on to clock up a string of
victories and remains one of the most
valuable and hotly desired racing cars
of all time for some people the greatest
Ferrari ever models have been auctioned
for up to 30 million dollars only 39
were built back to Giotto beats a rainy
after being recruited by Renzo la Volta
he created the easel grief Oh a
high-performance Gran Turismo with
American engineering on board
but bit sorry nee wanted more he built a
two-seater competition car based on the
grief oh his boss revolted wanted to
sell cars rather than burn money on the
racetrack however the two likewise
parted ways beat Serena took his latest
creation with him and named it the beat
Serena 5300 GT the v8 engine was like
that in the grief Oh taken from the
Chevrolet Corvette until anybody beat
Serena was the first to come up with a
front mid-engine explains proud owner
Ares engines on top of the axle have a
far higher center of gravity an engine
below and behind the axle is far lower
which gives you a massive advantage in
terms of handling it's still copy today
I think for texts read off what the CEO
of compute
until it fell off from the very start of
his career when he was making bigger
cars bit Cellini had a preference for
high-capacity American engines over
their smaller high powered Italian
rivals he also once tried to convince
Ferrari to construct a large
displacement engine with lower rev
levels dr. srinagar 30 seconds through
the 5.4 liter v8 complemented by a
battery of twin Weber carburetors pumps
out 360 horsepower and that's in the
basic version
the engine is unusually far back the
only access to the distributor cap was
via an opening on the dashboard
take to the wheel of a bit sorry knee
and your left and no doubt that it was
constructed for the track the
full-blooded v8 propelling a two-seater
weighing just eleven hundred kilos
delivers the kind of ferociousness
otherwise associated with modern super
sports cars that GT is not meant for a
jaunt in the countryside the 5300 GT was
launched into action on the track
against Ferrari to give beats are any
revenge for his dismissal by his former
employer and he did win a few times at
the one thousand kilometer race at Monza
in 1965 for example the 5300 GT left all
the GTOs in its tracks but the car maker
was unable to follow up on that success
not least because of a lack of funds
Eric Oswald's prize beauty is the first
of just 10 cores editions featuring a
lightweight body
but Serena is Serena went with this car
which previously had an aluminum body to
a boat construction in Italy together
they built a fiberglass body Pizza
reading then made nine more courses dong
dong oh no invite the course I'll skip
out
today the 5300 GT is a member of a very
exclusive club anyone who owns one will
be desperate to hold on to it potential
buyers are looking at a six-figure price
tag whatever condition it's in most
recently a 5,300 GT changed hands for
over a half a million euros for the vast
majority of auto aficionados avid Serena
will always be just a dream
you